hi i'm alex and i have one week to
figure out how the heck defrost 250
cupcakes
in five minutes maybe get i don't know
i love watching those mesmerizing
cupcake videos where the bakers pipe the
frosting in a perfect swirl so
consistently
and so fast so i asked the bakers at
georgetown cupcakes
how many cupcakes they can frost in five
minutes and they told me
250. now i'm a pretty competitive person
and i wanted to push myself but you know
practice makes perfect and if i'm gonna
be a pro
i gotta train like a pro so here i have
250 cupcakes five bags of frosting
and five minutes on the glock let's do
this
all stressed out here okay i'm ready
okay and go
oh no there's definitely something with
the swirl that i'm doing wrong
they look like poops three minutes okay
gotta get through these far ones first
maybe get i don't know
no two minutes you know how they say
there's like runner's high i feel like
i'm on like a cupcake frosting hi
oh okay just going with it
oops there's gotta be one in here that's
like good enough to be sold
right one that was pretty good
number six how do i harness the power of
number six
in all 250 this is gonna be a long week
[Music]
all right i am at home now i've set up
myself a little frosting station
so first i'm going to start with 30
seconds on the clock
i'm gonna try to get 25 cupcakes piped
i also want to really focus on learning
the technique of piping
i figured if i used an even bigger
piping tip it will be easier to squeeze
and hopefully my arm won't get as tired
as it did because
that was a workout oh god i'm nervous
again three
two one i can already tell that this
piping tip
is much easier i put 30 minutes on the
clock
so for that round i focused less on
technique again
and more on speed and i ended up getting
10 20
29 cupcakes done still gotta figure out
some way to improve my form
all right i'm taking a break from
frosting gonna eat some dinner but in
the meantime i'm gonna keep
practicing by watching professional
cupcake videos
look at how beautiful that frosting job
is
they start piping the inside of the
cupcake and move in a swirl
towards the upside hopefully i can
digest
some of these techniques along with my
dinner right peace out
the only person i'll take help from so
basically
i've been challenged to pipe 250
cupcakes in five minutes okay
so i know same you don't want to squeeze
right here
and you want to squeeze
hold this way okay and it goes
like that look at you
oh my gosh my frosting just glowed
up ready go
[Music]
30 seconds okay yeah but look how good
this is
not great i feel like speed wise you are
doing
great because you had five seconds left
and you're already
yeah i got through all of these ones
right here
technique-wise without the speed i was
doing way better
yeah it's just marrying the two thank
you for your help
okay so it's about 7am right now i woke
up a little bit early so i could get
some practice in
so i think if i keep going and working
on my
technique and form i'll naturally just
be able to get faster
after about 30 cupcakes my hand
starts to feel like it's about to fall
off so this round i started off
pretty good actually come around here
and then you can see about here is where
my hands started to cramp
but you know what it's improvement and
it's only up from here
[Music]
all right it's day four tomorrow's big
day i'm still over here practicing
i can tell you i have a whole new
appreciation for these cupcake frosters
though
to be honest i don't think i'm gonna be
able to get through all 250
especially if i'm trying to make them
look good but you know what i'm gonna
try and that's what matters
right hopefully that's what matters
i'm still developing my frosting muscles
you know i actually just switched the
direction of my swirl because i don't
know my
arm got tired and it seems to be working
even better
look at me go she frosts and she scores
oh should have done that
[Music]
don't fire me
[Music]
okay today is big day we've all been
waiting for
i wouldn't say i'm feeling too confident
this morning but
there's no going back okay i'm gonna put
one minute on the clock i'm gonna try to
get through all
50 on this sheet
[Music]
okay in one minute i got through 42
cupcakes
all right here we are the first row not
great but not too rad
and as always gets worse and worse
i do think this is the closest i've
gotten to maintaining both quality and
speed
although i was still ate short so
there's that but you know what maybe
when i get in there and adrenaline is
pumping
and the frosting is flowing miracles can
happen
maybe this onesie is lucky maybe i
should wear this
okay i'm at work i'm heading upstairs to
go attempt this challenge
and i actually just got a video message
from
georgetown cupcakes yeah like it's so
good georgetown
cake i heard you're trying to frost 250
cupcakes in five minutes
so i wanted to share some of our top
tips first you want to start with a nice
light and airy frosting so you want to
mix it on high speed for about five
minutes
and that way when you put in a bag
you're going to squeeze so hard with
your hands
second is technique you want to start in
the center of the cupcake go around in
the circle and end the burst of pressure
that's going to make sure that each
cupcake swirl is perfect and beautiful
and third and probably most important is
to always cross with confidence
once you start swirling don't stop
because once you start to hesitate or
wait for a bit your swirl is going to be
broken
i hope these tips are helpful and from
everyone at georgetown cupcake
good luck those are some great tips
i hope i can remember them when i'm
doing the challenge
and i guess we should just go for it
[Music]
freeze behind this team
[Music]
i've been practicing all week with
increments of 25 and 50
but i haven't again been able to
practice with the whole 250. so i'm a
little bit worried about the stamina
and the muzzle cramps ready
go oh my god we got past number six
that's all i wanted
confidence okay this onesie is really
hot actually maybe it wasn't the best
move
three minutes left
two minutes two minutes don't lose it
one minute and thirty seconds
[Music]
one minute or less okay consistency
consistency
15 seconds
[Music]
i always wanted to put my face in cake
and it's not like a good moment
some of them kind of got stuck and
flipped
uh some of them i just put my favorite
too
when i was practicing i always noticed
that i started off pretty strong
and then as my hand starts to cramp it
gets a little weaker
but i do think for the most part i kept
pretty good quality throughout
i still got a little bit of a swirl like
some
aren't great but
passable i think it's fair
oh my god this needs bragging rights
i would just like to thank georgetown
cupcakes for sending me those
tips that confidence really got me
through this challenge
and i'd like to thank you riya for
helping me with my technique i didn't do
anything but you
you did it i'd also like to thank my
onesie what better way to celebrate than
with a cupcake exactly cheers
you